welcome to zero playing capital G that
son what'swhat's name kazi ghulam ali
very good blitz player not very high
rated and over the watch s but is so yes
you see 25 something very good let's
player okay Ruby ain't it's not ideal
but now I was a bit stupid I play down
b5 a bit too quickly but is he doing the
Bishop g5 that's a strange move sorry
uncommon this placement of the bishop
Enda in their way I mean it's not like
terrible it's just a as I said not very
very frequently seen so we gave me the
bishops for no particular reason
ok
now came Bishop g7 I wasn't really
necessary to play that as they have okay
there's no particular point in playing
that I can also i could have played down
c65 immediately okay I probably it's not
not so important
yeah of course I have to get some
counter play in the center and encounter
place sounds like he has much play
hasn't that that's just not very good
actually so like D for now or not it's
not clear let's not spend too much time
on those decisions this is this is good
anyway so let's do it so cheeks here and
before it's really quickly hitting that
counter play so what's now queen deform
he might just castle short
he might just cancel short I'm a Bishop
c4 first but I mean castling short neck
smooth yeah that could be the point
really like windy for you just Castle
short and the whole thing looks looks a
bit strange it's very possible much
possible so f6 snow threat can take that
but if you well short castles my bishop
on CA this is not good no what did I do
wrong that's very interesting because
that white setup was just rubbish okay
wanted to go to be seven not to be six
which is completely useless yeah this is
why I wanted to go to be seven well okay
it will be tricky now if you play this
kind of mouse lippisch moose hunt it's
very uncomfortable
yeah I rugby 7s got Bishop a six so not
even that is happening wow what did I do
wrong interesting maybe d4 really I
don't get it d 4 was of course opening
up his diagonal for the bishop maybe
that was a mistake I don't believe white
set up in the slightest yeah that was
just not good at all ok at least I can
go Ruby seven now ok see attacking e5
young somehow he is
really got no decent move here in that
position ideas f6 now well go f6 myself
that looks terrible but maybe I have to
do it what have I done to deserve this
what a bad position and a bad game by me
okay come on it's lost anyway so let's
at least try to that wouldn't that won't
help her man came Wow slack pros I'm
probably d4 was bad I mean that whole
concept of taking on f6 ain't going age
four and so on that's just not any
that's just not good it's pretty clear
but I just played it badly afterwards
and Ian says equal but okay I don't
believe that if that is not good for
black then something Sarah seriously
wrong here so queen of three so what is
what is my mistake here it probably
really is t4 right okay now the engine
gives this with a clear advantage and of
course I threatened e takes before
that's very simple and now he hasn't he
doesn't have a sensible move actually if
he goes here then I go deform and that's
that's excellent for me it's basically
winning by the way if he takes I'm
controlling f5 ok so just that simple
move and the whole thing is completely
completely falling apart i'm 21 and now
i can go see 5 yeah and toki no no big d
bt IM plex KD better with
with this kind of parts so d44 really
was bad I was just thinking now Kim
sometimes sometimes you i played this
really too quickly I was just thinking
okay this is rubbish anyway let's let's
play quickly the thing is that I just
had this this this idea okay that he
will take with this which is rubbish
because i have e for higher and I saw
that idea opening up the diagonal but of
course you can take with the Jeep on and
if you look at this I'm sorry just a
little bit then you will recognize that
this isn't great for me because that
Bishop is just wrong it gets noisy fine
it's just bad it's just bad chess what
I'm playing even here I can go see 5 or
or Bishop e6 or anything it's just good
for me here you cannot take well he can
but sure it's not not helping him in any
way I also have this it's also pretty
clear advantage yeah I I made this
mistake that the other guys usually do
that is plain to quickly just playing
far too quickly him if I just think
about it for a bit then then I will of
course see that this is not great around
here what was already I was thinking
okay maybe here i can get to d4 but he
can actually just cancel short this is
this is the the point if I go like
whatever Queen D for something you just
cancelled short and now naija for I have
six this kind of thing and I'm in bad
shape this Bishop is just so much
stronger than my c8 bishop so from here
it's just very bad even though the
engine says equal a okay okay of course
it was that that was totally ridiculous
yeah I wanted this is a mouse sleep I
wanted to do this which at least covers
the seventh-ranked it makes a big
difference but ok I'm still
under pressure and I shouldn't be under
pressure I should be much better so the
real point was here just Bishop e6 is
good well this is this is an advantage
but there should be six is just much
much better it makes d4 far more
threatening and this is simply not
playable i am sorry i know here i'm
winning the winning stuff here okay next
time thanks for watching